[Musique]
je
deux cent soixante mètres de long 2
mille hommes 40 avions de combat
le charles de gaulle défi la mesure
embarquez à bord de ce géant des mers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour les pilotes c'est l'heure d'enfiler
la combinaison de vol on pourrait dire
les combinaisons voler au dessus de la
mer nécessite quelques précautions
supplémentaires froide en ce moment donc
on vole avec une
ils ont étanche
on a des objections
ce qu'on a des
et souhaite dans le vol relativement
chaud parce que
la combi étanche à l'école elle a une
info
ensuite on entend alors anti g et
ce combat que je mets ce dernier
sur le porte avions les pilotes forment
une caste à part on les appelle ni par
leur nom ni par leur grade
ils ont des surnoms voici donc grox
pilote de rafale depuis deux ans
rox prépare sa mission avec un autre
pilote et on n'y comprend pas grand
chose c'est normal ils parlent pilotes
je te rappelle les repères ce sera un
étagement nul tu me lis mon casque sur
l'horizon si l'on sait les repères de ps
standard je te lâche 2 189 600 pieds
je voudrais créer 17 secondes sur
l'avant du bâtiment tu perdras de 25
secondes derrière
donc c'est une mission de closer
supporte dans des missions l'image de ce
faire en afghanistan
le but c'est de venir en appui de
fantassins qui sont au sol qui sont en
liaison radio avec nous et qui nous
désignerons des objectifs à traiter avec
notre armement pour les aider à
progresser ou à se défendre
au même moment sur le pont d'envol les
chiens jaunes entre en scène
leur nom vient tout simplement de la
couleur de leurs vêtements qui doivent
être bien visible ici ce sont eux les
patrons leur mission les mouvements des
avions sur le pont d'envol et pour les
aider une simple maquette fera de deux
semaines entre les ascenseurs doctorat
en 3 le samedi 7 et 11 4 le cem de
maquettes donc ils vont permettre de
savoir où se trouve chaque avion ça
pendant vol tout simplement ans il
demanda le rafale 21 je sais
qu'actuellement un parking avant
sixièmement on veut le descendre en
gardant le mettra alors sur le hangar
adéquate et là vous avez lang a
représenté de l'autre côté on sait
exactement où et chaque année le maître
amaro et chiens jaunes depuis trois ans
c'est la seule femme à ce poste en
france l'équipement en portant on envoie
de la brassière indispensable
le suppléait c'est notre outil de
travail
il avait deux parkings millions
on peut recevoir jusqu'à 5 super
étendard car on peut avoir aussi 4 apple
ou le hawk eye et de rafales donc là
c'est un parti ni on va dire date en
sera pas tout car angers le hawk eye
le voici c'est cet avion équipé d'un
puissant radar chargé de surveiller les
mouvements aériens
[Musique]
pour faire décoller les avions c'est un
véritable ballet qui se met en place une
dizaine de métiers différents intervient
c'est pour les voici en marron les
techniciens que vont ce qui fait de nous
accueillir les pilotes et c'est que des
pilotes pour t'occuper de l'avion vous
avez le chef d'equipe cas le brassard
blanc et vous avez les brassards rouges
qui votent les cars bus qui vont
s'occuper de faire aller plein sur les
avions enfin qu'ils puissent repartir
tout à l'heure dans une condition
[Musique]
en endurance
la routine à bord d'un porte avions on
ne connaît pas vraiment ce jour-là
exercice anti incendie grandeur nature
près de 500 hommes mobilisés incarne
d'équipage
je vous confirme l'ouverture du corridor
[Musique]
expliquez vous à d'autres acteurs là on
lutte contre un sinistre dans un poste
on a évacué deux manières réflexe toute
la presse était potentiellement
sinistrés dans laquelle on peut
retrouver des fumées et on est en train
de faire partir un groupe avec les
pompiers lourd que vous voyez derrière
moi qu'ils sont en gris afin de lutter
directement contre le sinistre sur un
navire transportant des munitions de
l'essence et des missiles nucléaires
la lutte contre les incendies est une
priorité pour laquelle on s'entraîne de
manière régulière de manière intensive
comme vous pouvez le voir parler pour
lequel l'ensemble du bourg est formée en
fait depuis
le plus simple matelot en passant par
les équipes spécialisées de la brigade
sécurité et enfin vous verrez on le
jouera tout à l'heure l'ensemble du bord
peut être sollicités dans le cadre d'un
événement qui sera amené à dépasser nos
moyens
le charles de gaulle est un immense
immeuble neuf le temps 20 étages des
kilomètres de couloirs
malgré ses dimensions l'espace est
compté les cabines des hommes du rang
accueille 18 personnes dans 40 mètres
carrés de simples couchettes et une
petite salle commune pour se détendre
le soir certains d un bouquin certains
regardent un film sur l'ordi portable à
la télé un film collectif le bord des
foires en mer ne passe un film par un
soir donc du coup de l'été lire à la
chaîne du bord qui permet de suivre un
film certains vont aux sports certains
vont téléphoner chaque personne vit
différemment mais on est tous ensemble
vraiment se pose là
pour le pilote l'heure du catapultage
approche
[Musique]
dernière vérification sur le rafale un
avion à plus de 100 millions d'euros
l'unité
[Musique]
en
dans le vacarme des réacteurs impossible
de s'entendre pour communiquer avec
rocks lemaitre amaro utilise un langage
des signes
un peu particulier
[Musique]
tu me faire avancer l'avions déjà
l'avion qu'est soap et on va lui faire
lâcher les freins auparavant c'est là je
le dirigeais droit l'âge de tigane sur
ma droite la somme à gauche là cela pour
faire freiner
donc là il est freiné il est stoppé
[Musique]
elle est deuxième partie un bond de 12 m
et on va tout sur les yannick lallemand
fait
démarrer
[Musique]
le rafale de rock va être catapulté en
deux secondes
l'avion passe de 0 à plus de 250 km
heure
[Musique]
dans l'accélération le poids de rops et
multiplié par quatre
sur le pont d'envol les catapultage
s'enchaînent 1 toutes les 30 secondes
ce sont les mêmes avions qui sont
intervenus en afghanistan et en libye
la passerelle de navigation
[Musique]
ici aussi la tension est palpable pour
les catapultage le porte avions doit
naviguer à la bonne vitesse
d'abord stop
la rend toujours ses louanges des cas
précis attendons d'un faux pas du moment
je suis en paix
[Musique]
de mettre la route pour assurer la bonne
vitesse
et la bonne route pour m
[Musique]
je surveille
comment varie le vent
trois des thématiques
[Musique]
pour manoeuvrer le porte-avions pas de
gouvernail mais une simple manette
semblable à celle des jeux vidéo
cet homme a la lourde tâche de commander
le porte avions à bord
on l'appelle le pacha
[Musique]
alors l'image que je prendrai la plus
simple c'est celle d'une communauté
urbaine qu'en fait j'ai plein de village
qui font des métiers différents jets les
villages des atomicien le village de
mécanicien d'avion et le métier des
opérations sur le bateau le village de
du pont d'envol et donc mon travail ça
consiste à synchroniser ses de ces
villages à faire que chacun réponde aux
besoins opérationnels en phase avec
notre village
et sur certaines activités typiquement
celle de catapulter ont ramassé des
avions c'est quasiment 90% des villages
du bateau qu'ils sont motivés sur la
mission
les suivantes
[Musique]
quelques étages plus bas à bord on y
répond changement d'ambiance pour
fonctionner un porte-avions a aussi
besoin d'une laverie
deux mille hommes à bord cela fait
beaucoup de linge plus de deux tonnes
par jour
m
comment vous faites pour plaire aux
perdants dans tout cela on a des fiches
japon
des fiches avec le gisement le numéro de
poste
services ainsi que le nom de la personne
qui nous emmène loin et c'est dans les
zac
comme vous voyez ici est en fait un sac
par sac tout ce qui est ensemble on est
ensemble
s'il ya plusieurs sacs
mêlant le maître le bouquet mara
travaille ici depuis deux ans comme
toutes les femmes de l'équipage et les
loger dans un espace séparé strictement
interdit aux hommes à bord du charles de
gaulle un homme sur dix et une femme et
en tant que femme à bord vous avez des
difficultés
il n'y a pas de souci
les hommes font
on a par son
contre les femmes à bord
voyons d'avoir mai
on nier
on va refaire marcher nécessaire voilà
le charles de gaulle c'est également
4000 repas page
quatre restaurants dont deux savent
services pour les hommes du rang et des
salles réservées aux officiers
la nourriture c'est quand quelque chose
de très important
c'est à oran où les gens ou entre eux
peuvent discuter peuvent se distraire ce
soit partagée surtout sur porte-avions
des pilotes
on fait encore son épisode et à des
réservations c'est des pilotes de haut
vol dont ils ont besoin de bien manger
tout ça contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait penser ont vite enfermé à bord
d'un porte-avion aucun hublot le petit
peu qu'on peut voir le jour on essaie
d'en profiter
sinon à les placer mais la plupart du
temps de la journée vous voyez pour
faire la distinction entre le jour et la
nuit
les couloirs sont éclairé en rouge
[Musique]
le rafale c'est un peu la formule 1 du
ciel un avion ultra performant qui doit
tout de même passé de temps en temps
dans les mains des mécaniciens
c'est quand même assez intéressante
d'ailleurs
après bon c'est vrai quoi rythme est
soutenu mais bon c'est vous permet de
pas nous ennuyer
un métier passionnant qui a aussi ses
contraintes les missions en mer peuvent
durer plusieurs mois
[Musique]
ces lavages arme principale pour moi
personnellement
une en plus une rondelle de commandes de
ferrures de chez les caps
moi j'ai commencé à 8 heures on a fini à
11h10 la relève après 2
2 comment va de 11h à
une heure on va manger l'après midi on
est on a une commune un repos la plupart
du temps on fait une sieste pour pouvoir
récupérer un petit peu quoi et voilà cet
après midi on n'a pas pu faire de sieste
parce qu'il y avait il y avait un
exercice juste là on a fait un petit peu
une journée non stop
mais bon avec les chanter comme ça c'est
vachement intéressant donc c'est plus
motivant
là vous allez travailler
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin c'est la butée
[Musique]
un peu à l'écart un homme croque les
mécaniciens un peintre invité
exceptionnellement sur le porte avions
tout est réuni
toutes les réunions que tout
technologique
[Musique]
tout est technique
le moindre objet ou moins de route tout
est technique et l
l'homme qui vient se servir de tous
acquis à penser ça me fascine
m'intéresse c'est le mouvement et
l'ambiance
une ambiance très particulière avec son
attente et ils vont se préparer
[Musique]
mais à partir sur l'église
manga
ces bruits
laudun
ça
il a travaillé dans des conditions comme
celles-là 6 3
[Musique]
la malade on ne
qu'avec moi il est parti fumer
imaginerait c'est mon pote
[Musique]
un peu plus loin ambiance moins
artistique les fusilliers marins tous
les jours ces soldats répètent les mêmes
gestes
vous nous expliquer ce que vous êtes
on progresse un tube
le matelot palais ni fait partie de ces
soldats d'élite
leur mission empêcher toute intrusion et
demi à bord aujourd'hui localisation et
neutralisation de deux pirates
[Musique]
seul un peu dur de se concentrer ferrer
de choses
plus de militaires
ce qui s'explique
projection défense spécialement c'est
car anesthésié spécialisation
pragma dans le
au civil par yvan
avoir une maligne
de certains moments
[Musique]
certaine cohésion
dre est différente
[Musique]
m
la mission de rock se termine pour
rejoindre le porte-avions il va devoir
affronter la phase la plus délicate du
vote
[Musique]
et quelles que soient les mouvements du
pont l'état de la mer il faut
il faudra six chars trajectoire faire
confiance aux filles et d'appontage
toute façon environ
tard diront d'affronter s'il considère
que les conditions ne sont pas réunies
pour le faire
donc les vitesses d' approche la du
rafale ces ports de 250 km/heure et on
est arrêté sur une quarantaine de mètres
par les brins d'arrêt
[Musique]
les années
le travail de rocks est loin d'être
finie il va maintenant devoir débriefer
sa mission et préparer la suivante
[Musique]
sur le fond les appontages se succèdent
le maître amaro est toujours à la
manoeuvre pour elle travailler ici est
avant tout une passion plaisir d'être en
cours et avec les avions ça métier
passionnant de même